we are learning new details this morning
about an unprecedented global sting
operation
law enforcement officials say operation
trojan shield dealt a
major blow against international crime
even preventing
dozens of murders jeff begays has more
this morning more than 800 criminals
across 16 countries have been arrested
in an
unprecedented sting operation law
enforcement seized over 30 tons of drugs
some hidden in everything from
pineapples to cans of tuna
fish 250 firearms luxury cars and nearly
50 million dollars in cash and
cryptocurrency
the fbi says operation trojan shield
also disrupted more than 150 planned
killings
the amount of intelligence that we
received was staggering
the historic operation was made possible
by an app called
anim designed by the fbi to lure
suspects from the shadows
the agency made 12 000 devices with the
anim software
available on the black market
advertising them as secure
encrypted devices the criminals using
these devices believe they were secretly
planning crimes far beneath the radar of
law enforcement but in reality
the criminals were not underneath the
radar they were
on it the fbi was monitoring those
conversations
while the criminals messaged each other
they were unknowingly sending
carbon copies of their communications to
law enforcement
on adam criminal communicated in 45
languages
about things like trafficking in drugs
arms
and explosive atm gas attacks
armed robberies and last but not least
contract killings
over 18 months law enforcement
intercepted more than 27 million
messages the vast majority related to
criminal activity like drug trafficking
and murder plots the very devices that
the criminals used
to hide their crimes were actually a
beacon
for law enforcement a beacon for law
enforcement that is now
shut down investigators were asked
yesterday well why go public with this
encrypted device if it's working for law
enforcement and against the criminals
well investigators told us that they
believe if needed they can create
another device like that
anthony they say they just want to keep
the criminals guessing staggering
operation jeff thank you very much